welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 74 with andy no andy noe
is a journalist who recently released a
book
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan to
destroy democracy
there's rioting going on from antifa
last week the riots were bad enough that
one of my good friends who lives in
minneapolis
left his home and the city they're
calling in military police
to protect the city if you look at the
news they're either not covering the
fact there were people with molotov
cocktails throwing them around the
streets in certain areas
or they're saying these riots are
alt-right and white supremacists
mixed in with legitimate protesters but
that's not what it looks like on the
ground
so i spoke to andy because he's been on
the ground you can listen to this
episode
if you're open enough to consider that
antifa isn't what mainstream media is
telling you it is
please remember to hit subscribe if you
enjoy this content i'm still demonetized
since last july i do have a donor box
linked in my description if you want to
support that way but i also just
appreciate the subscriptions
this episode is brought to you by a
kratom sponsor superspeciosa
kratom is a herb related to the coffee
plant the leaves or extracts from the
leaves have been used as a stimulant and
a sedative
it works on opiate receptors in the
brain so it's been used to treat chronic
pain
digestive ailments and aid in withdrawal
from opiate dependence
there have also been reports of kratom
abuse but whenever you try anything
don't be stupid don't drink 12 cups of
coffee a day or you'll get withdrawal
do your research and decide for yourself
i myself like kratom and think it can be
beneficial if used properly
i've used it as a substitute for coffee
coffee doesn't make me feel good
or as an overall calming tea i know how
hard this year has been and is on people
and something like kratom tea for just
chilling out is safer in my opinion than
a pharmaceutical
it's very effective superspeciosa has
different strains some help you relax
some give you energy
their kratom is reliable third-party lab
tested and approved under the american
kratom association's quality standards
program
only pure natural kratom no other
ingredients
visit getsuperleaf.com mp
to buy small servings or in bulk uh
either way you'll be saving a lot of
money to get
guaranteed high quality kratom so if you
want to try kratom you can get 20
off by going to getsuperleaf.com mp
and entering code mp for 20 off
i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
mr andy noe welcome to my podcast
my pleasure thanks for having me on my
kayla
i think this is timely given what's been
going on in the u.s
but can we start with you giving a brief
background about who you are
and what it is you do so
i am a journalist i'm most known for my
coverage
uh of antifa i had a book that came out
in february
of this year it became a new york times
bestseller it's called unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy and it highlights
and chronicles the riots of
2020 as well as um
detailing the groundwork that happened
several years before
then for that violence to take place
so it's kind of a i wrote it to be a
one-stop place for the average reader to
go to
to understand what antipa is
um what their ideology calls for what um
what are the tactics and strategies and
also just as misconceptions
about the ideology and movement
okay so can we just start off before we
delve into things um can you give me a
background about
what antifa is and whether or not it's
organized centrally or just a brief
background about what antifa is would be
good to start
yeah i'm glad you asked that and because
there is a lot of misinformation about
antifa out there from both the left and
the right
so i'll start with one of the biggest
mistakes i see which is when people
describe think of antifa as a a single
capital a
organization with like h one antifa
leader
as if it was some hierarchical
international organization where if you
take out
the top the whole thing will crumble
it's not like that
so when the fbi had last year
infamously said that antifa uh
is an ideology and then later that was
echoed by
um then candidate biden
those statements and those in themselves
are not actually wrong but they're
incomplete
so you have to think of antifa as an id
one an ideology but also a mutant and
networks of groups and cells
so you can have people who are involved
in
antifa groups where antifa is not even
in the name
for example um there are cells of the
youth
liberation front they don't use the word
antifa in it but
that the portland chapter of that group
was the one that was responsible for
organizing the months of rioting that
happened in the pacific northwest
last year so um like
i don't you know don't get too caught up
on the name
like how you can identify what they are
is
based on the what they actually um
say so their ideology broadly
is anarchist communists that's why they
wave
the black flag and the red flag black
representing anarchy
red communism so they
what they're trying to do is to destroy
all
government um and with with that comes
all of the lower l um fruits
of liberalism rule of law um
freedom of expression so that's why they
have
you know they they strike at the heart
of things that matter
to the most people who care about rights
and liberties such as you know they will
physically assault people for holding
the wrong ideas or
ideas that they say are fascist
um and it's not you don't even have to
even
say um you don't even have to like be
out there holding
um a rally that they disagree with you
can express
views that they disagree with online and
they'll go
and assault you given the opportunity
they attack facilities and institutions
associated
uh with criminal justice system so
um courts um
uh police stations of course i'm
speaking to you as
we we're having now a new round of
really bad violence in the united states
i mean last
night antifa in portland set the
um police union hall on fire and you can
see videos of the flames are going
20 feet up from the ground and this is
something they've done dozens of times
so yeah they want to overturn everything
so when they say
burn it down burn this [ __ ] down
[ __ ] police kill police they actually
mean that kill
nazis um and of course as
um you and your family probably
probably understand better than anybody
um but
when they who they describe nazi is kind
of meaningless
it's just applied to anybody that they
disagree with and i know that sounds
kind of like a cop-out but
it it's actually true so they will apply
it from
they can actually do apply to people who
are actually neonates they apply to
people who are trump supporters
um people who wave the american flag
people who disagree with
social justice identity politics people
who are critical of crt
any all that they would describe as
fascistic
and signs of being part of the far right
okay where did this uh do you know the
origins of where this came from
yeah i wrote about in the book so the
antifa um
paramilitary types organizing and the
symbols that they use
like their logos and the the
the two flag um symbol that you'll see
them off then
wearing or waving in the air that is
a takes inspiration from
the original antifa capitol antifa which
was
a parent military of the german
communist party
back in the 1930s so if you go back
historically
as well there is a certain precedent
for the actions of antifa today in that
um in the in the interwar years in the
obama republic just before world war
ii um you had a lot of political
violence
in the weimar republic you had communist
fascists and all these political groups
having their own
paramilitaries beating up their rivals
uh doing assassinations and the antifa
at that time was
were a group of the uh the communists
and they were essentially uh street bugs
for them
so they were going around beating up uh
and this is the one misconception that's
out there
they weren't targeting the actual nazis
they were going after the social
democrats which
were um the ruling governing party
of the walmart republic at that time so
and i write about this in the book but
some historians
argue that that this uh
tense period of back and forth
um political violence between these
groups polarized the public
in and created a reaction where the
people
wanted their one of the violence to stop
and wanted a restoration of rule and
order
so even if they didn't um
uh like uh hitler's anti-semitism for
example
they liked his sort of strong man appeal
and all that and that
that paved the way in some regards for
hitler to gain more supporters and
followers
so and then uh
um the world were to happen uh
uh from the ashes of that in the carving
out
of uh what would become east germany
under communist rule
the communist anti-fascist ideology was
instituted at the state level in east
germany so
a lot of people aren't familiar with
like
the berlin wall which is constructed by
um the the east germans to prevent their
own people from fleeing to the west
um that was called officially the
anti-fascist defense
barrier so again another example of how
anti-fascist it doesn't really mean
being against nazis or anything it's
being
against communism so um
in the answer today borrow that
history and um story
and claim it as this is there's not a
direct connection um
the yeah so a lot of history there
um that's kind of the shortened version
okay what's been what's been happening
recently because i know
uh the person who runs the podcast is in
minnesota and
he's moved because of rioting so
what is what's going on all over the u.s
recently
and are these different separate
factions of antifa that aren't
associated with each other or
or what's what's happening yeah so i can
appreciate that your audience includes
people
from all over the world so kind of sum
up um
people may have been seeing videos from
the past 72
hours um showing all um
variety not just in portland but um in a
in a city called brooklyn center which
is
just north of minneapolis so the
the trial of derek chauvin which is the
former police officer accused
killing george floyd is ongoing so
there's already been a lot of propaganda
going on now from for weeks and months
really putting people on the edge uh
making them feel tense uh because they
want a particular outcome in that trial
the trial is ongoing and three days ago
earlier this week there was a police
involved shooting death of a
violent criminal suspect named dante
wright now he he became the latest
blm martyr his mother came out and said
that
her son was killed because of the police
disagreeing about an air freshener in
his car which is
[ __ ] there's nothing to substantiate
that he was getting arrested
for a warrant um over charges of
aggravated robbery where he's accused of
choking repeatedly a woman and robbing
her at gunpoint
and he resisted arrest um and
tried to escape and he has pending had
trending charges of another previous
escape however
uh the body cam footage has been
released and it appears that the
female officer who shot him meant to use
a taser
so he died and this was caused
uh i think because it's close to
minneapolis
and on top of that the these whole
networks
of blm and antifa are really really good
at getting out
disinformation and lives to get their
base
and supporters angry and so
uh immediately you had all these
protests organized from coast to coast
and we're seeing a repeat essentially of
things that happened just before george
floyd died i mean
there was before george floyd died last
year there were several other
high-profile cases there was uh like
ahmed arbury
brianna taylor so you know they're kind
of
using every story as like a very big
stepping stone
and wright's death was a significant one
because it gave them
another um tragedy to exploit
and um so
uh you asked about like how connected
are all these anti-fur
cells and groups they are they organize
autonomously but they are connected in
that they communicate with one another
online primarily through
telegram and signal so
and also on twitter as well so a lot of
the
organizing in terms of here's
we're announcing a direct action
riot for this time in place come with
the flyer
that that type of stuff is distributed
all over social media
instagram twitter it's not taking down
the accounts that are
promoting and that are uh making this
propaganda flyers
and sharing it they're not getting taken
down but in terms of like
um organizing the you know
getting the right gear together shields
helmets
umbrellas you'll see that a lot um and
that type of organizing is done by
encrypted apps because
i mean a lot of it is criminal and
because as part of
the organizing they bring weapons like
hammers bats guns
and molotov cocktails and
accelerant liquids to stop buyers
what are their goals
so uh when i was giving the intro to
antifa
i was speaking um broadly about
antifa ideology but kanera
gamma let's say in specifically the
american context
their goal is the american antifa's
goal is to destabilize
certain areas of the country because
that's a much more realistic goal for
them than
like toppling the federal government
um so it's it's a multi-prong approach
one of the biggest things that they've
always they've had always advocated for
is
getting rid of police that was always a
pipe dream for them
and if you go back you know maybe two
years ago that was
would have been laughable in the u.s but
you can see how in a very short amount
of time you're having police departments
that are defunded
by uh the tens of millions hundreds of
millions on the case in
nypd a billion with b dollars
and the effect of that is escalating
violence and crimes in these areas
because when you cut back on the
resources for law enforcement they're
not going to be able to
respond in time to lower priority
calls so short of like literally
uh an absolute emergency that's the top
priority you're not going to have police
come
so um
and in portland portland is great
portland oregon is a great uh
case study and and what happens uh when
antifa's
demands are are playing out so
the police department there as in other
places are is hammering in that
it was already at a low number of
offices before and now it's at record
low
numbers and when antifa arriving
police just don't have the resources to
respond
so um two days ago when they
uh set some fires and
just destroyed the front of a police
station in southeast portland
there was like 200 antifa there
and there police made no rest not a
single rest
because they just didn't have the
resources the best they could do
was to chase them away after they had
already done all this damage
and had already pre-announced that they
were going to be doing it
and then last night around more than 100
of them went to
try to burn down the police union
there's one arrest
and the other thing is the district
attorney has been elected in portland
in san francisco in other cities these
are
district attorneys who are
self-described as progressive i would
call them far less
in that they believe that their role is
to subvert
essentially justice by not
prosecuting most criminals because they
believe in what is equity
that the district attorneys
have they say historically prosecuted
too many black people
so they need to not do that so you're
having literally
a revolving door system we had months
and months a night
nightly riots in portland last year in
of the thousand arrests throughout 2020
associated to the political violence
more than 90 of the cases have just been
dropped
like not even investigated they just as
a matter of policy
they just get dropped of the district
attorney so you're having people who
are getting arrested i think the most
that i counted
because i tracked all this was eight
arrests for one person
and they don't get a go to get in any
legal trouble
so literally they can get arrested one
night be released by the morning and
return to be violence again
uh within 24 hours so
we're seeing this repeated in varying
degrees in many cities
and anthony's goal is to create this
context where they can actually
do what they want and face and get away
with it
because you know they want to create
autonomous zones like all over america
um and you know doing that in
a really republican conservative area
would be impossible for them but doing
it in a place like portland and seattle
sounded impossible uh before last year
but they actually did
make autonomous zones there uh chazz
you may have heard the capitol hill
autonomous zone in seattle washington
that went on for more than three weeks
and it was a
militant group of people who were armed
who took over
six blocks of city public property
and property that included high rises
and apartments where people live
and it turned into a zone of death in my
opinion that was there on the ground
there were four firsts there were fights
all over and then there were attempted
rapes
and shootings shootings over and over
and over led to two homicides
um including one of a black
child nobody's been arrested over that
minneapolis has an autonomous zone right
now they're calling it the george
floyd autonomous zone that's been going
on for
uh since may of last year and police
should stay away from
from that area and so like
yeah if you you know all
you know to even make it more simple
when people say what do you have to want
how bad can
it be i just say look at the areas where
they've been given the space to do what
they want look at the autonomous sense
that that is that is that is antifa's
vision
put into to practice reality on the
ground
go look at it go live in it if you want
and you'll see what their
vision is next for more areas
i suppose if you wanted to create a
system of anarchy the first thing you
would do would be to
destroy the police that's just lots of
logical way just to create a zone of
anarchy
like who can get us in trouble police
okay they're the bad guys get rid of
them and then we can do what we want
uh is there a reason that
this isn't is this front page news
anywhere that there are these zones
no and when it uh when there was
national coverage about the seattle
autonomous zone last year it was
positive and in favor of them actually
they were describing it as
festive a block party uh
the mayor of seattle when she was asked
about it on cnn said that it could be a
somewhere of love
the governor was asked about it in the
early days and he had he said he wasn't
even aware that had happened
because this is how clueless these
politicians are and this is how
lying some of the mainstream presses
actually
i would say all of it particularly in
print uh
lying is too strong a word i would say
extremely biased
in that they um
they present a a false
they presented reality that is true in
one very small sliver
it's like it's like for example i get
criticized
i got criticized by a lot of the media
when i was highlighting the riots last
year and i was talking about how bad it
was
because to me it's it's
it should not be tolerated that we're
having this type like
groups of armed people
taking over areas of the public night
after night after night
and the response in the press was oh my
videos are just showing a really small
area of portland
look how nice portland is in this part
of the city
look at me enjoying my lunch my my drink
in this nice pot there's no writing here
like you know they set up the straw man
it's like
it's like uh you know i'm not saying
nothing
at 24 7 at every inch of the city things
look like hell of course not
it's that big parts of downtown
in increasingly residential areas
you never know when it's even safe to
drive down the road because these
riots are organized they can take place
anytime
drivers who have them get caught in it
will get their cars matched up they'll
get assaulted they'll get attacked
if you happen to live in some of these
areas that they targeted
i mean they sat in a building on fire
when they were trying to ride outside
mad ted wheeler's house they started
building a wire that was attached to
an apartment that had like multiple
units to it like
in what world is this is this normal and
okay
and unfortunately that type of um
response to the riots was quite routine
um uh in a lot of the press i saw
and um so it
created you know those who were raising
their lawns
like myself and some other independent
journalists we were deemed
the ones who were the problem and then
there led to
shooting deaths and stabbings
so how many of these riots have you
actually gone into
dozens in portland so um that was where
i was primarily based on the ground last
year because i was writing the book
unmasked and it was important for me to
actually be there but i've been going
since
about 2016. so you know if you counted
all
uh yeah several dozen going back
years now and that in the first time i
was caught in one of these rides
was when i was a student journalist at
the end of 2016 when it was known that
trump had won the election and the
response in portland
was well at that time i'd said pierre
anarchy
it really appeals in comparison to what
we've been experiencing
um last year and this year at that time
you had thousands of people take to the
street to
i mean it's one thing to be upset that
your your preferred candidate didn't win
but they
it wasn't that they rejected the
legitimacy
of the electoral process in america
and so they said that trump was an
illegitimate
president and their response was to be
violent so you had organized
mobs of people dressed in black covering
their faces
which at that time was unusual and
carrying
melee weapons and going around and
destroying businesses and cars
and starting fires and streets and they
were doing it and they were
given the legitimacy by the press both
local
and national and and this is really
crucial because
they have to really they have to depend
on that positive coverage and the spin
because they need a certain amount of
buy-in from the ignorant
liberal left you know like the number of
people
who are actually um actively involved in
militant anti-flag tactics are
relatively small
and they're not too effective if they
don't have a huge number of people that
they can sort of
blend in with which is why they need to
exploit deaths
like of george floyd or or um
dante wright and others to
to make their message a bit more
palatable and unfortunately we had a
press
that was telling us day in and day out
um when trump won
it's that this was ascendant american
fascism in america that it was an
emergency that it needed all hands on
deck
resistance and resistance is a term
for war by the way and that's how
the other side was thinking of it and so
it they completely legitimized all this
political violence
and then in 2017 we had really small
alt-right gatherings i know uh
charlottesville people will always the
left will always go
to that because the messaging was
was so racist and ugly and all that but
there was only a couple hundred people
there
and it was framed as a an event that
represented everything about america
and there were lots of antifa who came
there
with the specific goal and they carried
it out of being
a beat trying to assault people to beat
up people
and that led to clashes and one of those
clashes
led to uh one of the alt-right guys
uh ramming his car into a bunch of these
people in it
and it um one of them was killed
and it's like you know my analysis of
all this is that i think antifa
creates the um enemies that they say
they're out there to fight
like they there is a certain reaction on
the far right when i
read their their messages or go on their
forums to try to understand
better about the extremism uh
they feel like anthony says extremism
because the state is not responding to
it
that it's getting legitimized in the
mainstream
that it's up to them to organize counter
far-right type of events and all that
and
so that's a growing reaction in response
to ants because
violence extremism um
and you know and that and that's just
talking about the true far right
you also see that because there's not
enough
of these enemies and to have to make
them up
and they often make them up out of thin
air and you know they'll go after
[Music]
myself or people like your father or
other people who are
um like center
right maybe i i myself identified
central right
uh other people they've gone after like
um they don't have enough enemies so
they have to
stick certain labels to people they
oppose
and in 2019 that was their justification
when they beat me severely
on the streets of downtown portland and
nearly killed me i had a brain bleed
and was hospitalized and uh nobody's
been
uh arrested much has charged over that
and that's
more than a year and a half ago
did they do that because they recognized
you
they did so this is when i was
um i would say more naive in that
i knew i was hated at that time like a
lot of the people have been
from uh for more than six months at that
point have been
confronting me at these protests but i
stood my ground
i'm like look this is a public
whatever you're doing it's taking split
space um
taking place in public me as
a independent freelance journalist it is
my right and i will stand by it
to go and to document it to document
what's happening in public and so they
were
started throwing things at me but i
never thought that they would have
played to the point of where they would
in an organized manner be like punched
me repeatedly
in the face and head um and that's how i
i think there was a brass knuckle that
one of them was
wearing that's how i probably got the
brain bleed
but you know it like it was it was quick
but i mean those
30 seconds or so they felt like forever
and i couldn't
when it was happening i could still sort
of see the
um the sheriff's office it happened
right from the sheriff's office we were
like in the heart of downtown
so there's like security cameras all
over the buildings
a whole bunch of people have their
cameras out recording this attack
and i was just thinking the police were
going to come at any moment to like
help me right like a person of the media
is getting
beat up by thugs in the street and of
course they're going to come help no
they never did at any point and so
um you know i i'm known for being a
defender of the police but
i mean one thing that many conservative
americans have this impulse to
stand with the blue i i stand with
um i stand with the rule of law and i if
if police departments are under corrupt
leadership
or influenced by corrupt politics and
politicians
you're gonna see that reflected in the
orders that are given
to the officers on the ground who are
instructed to
do exactly what they told so they're
told to
not intervene they don't intervene
even when they see um
journalists being beaten up um
so i mean that was part of the reason
eventually
late last year why i had to leave
portland i was
already on borrowed time i have been
fully doxed
by uh antifa so people were showing up
to my house
quite frequently to intimidate me and
all of this was being reported to police
it was like
it's really it's emotionally draining
the whole experience of
being intimidated at your home like that
and then two
going through the process of reporting
it to law enforcement where it's very
clear that
they're doing it as a matter of policy
to take a report but
there was never any follow-up on any of
this even when i did my own
investigative work to identify some of
these suspects
who were sending me death threats or
showing up on my home
and nothing was fine either so you know
the writing was on the wall that
um it was too dangerous
for me to continue doing it and you
asked like how many of these
riots and protests i've been to in 2020
i had to change up my tactics every
single time i was going
because um they were they were actively
looking for me
so even though i was like massed up and
all that they were looking for people
who had my
similar body shape they were looking for
people who had similar
eyes if my eyes were showing and many
times i got it wrong
they were they went after the wrong east
asian person because they thought it was
me
so it's really dangerous so i have
a lot of respect for the independent
journalists who
who are on the ground covering this
stuff you know when you're in the middle
of a riot it
it is terrifying especially if you're
not
wearing a gas mask and like have
essentially
um body armor on because these
uh impact munitions are flying all over
people during projectiles
tear gas is in the air so it hurts to
breathe it hurts to open your eyes
um but you know if we're not the ones
doing that type of footage
you're not going to be seeing this
anywhere
that's absurd
so i what like what's the plan
is there anything people can do or is it
just spread awareness online
do you what do you think i'm glad you
asked that
um so i recently learned
about the term black pills and i think
that's how i feel
about america that was part of my
feeling so dejected about the state of
things is one of the reasons why
i left at least for now i left the
country i've
spoken about being in the uk for a bit
now
um there's not
i'm not entirely sure if there's much
that can be done to be honest because
it for a long time now is no secret that
like
all these other institutions and
sections of society have been captured
by
the critical race theorists last so
academe
obviously uh entertainment journalism
uh local governments depending on the
city and
the trump administration was like the
one
bullwork and it was an important bulwark
because it was at the federal
executive level and with him
not with there being a new
administration who
not it's not just sympathetic to
critical race theory and hard luck but
really
leans into it i'm referring to people
like
uh vice president right now who actually
helped fund
crowd fund for people who were accused
and arrested over rioting in minnesota
last year
in people who were accused of attempted
break
and attempted murder she fundraised for
the minnesota freedom fund
that should make people be sick and
she's never had an answer for that
and it makes me sorry to go in a tirade
so yeah with the uh the federal
government also falling to this
and as we've learned from the reporting
that's come out after the election that
the whole
electoral process in the united states
is being shifted in a way that
advantages democrats essentially rigging
the system in a way
i think there's a certain amount of
merit to that statement
um and you're not a conspiracy theorist
when you can point to
uh the things that have been done um
in certain swing states that were
critical for
biden winning this time um
yeah put all that together i'm not
really
um hopeful for
the the president near future and
but for what can be done what can be
done
is um
i don't think this um fighting back
against the hard left
we cannot win without buy-in from the
mainstream left
and so like the times that i've given
testimony to congress and all that
i i came with the non-partisan message i
came with the evidence citing affidavits
citing police press statements
um and talking about what aunties love
themselves are said about democrats
because i'm trying to show that hey
we're facing
a extremism threat from something that
happens to be far less but
it threatens all of us um but that
message was always ignored and
i was demonized by liberals so
um there isn't that buying that we're
seeing
um you know you can even you know when
you're looking at like how
like centrist voices at uh papers of
like
records have been pushed out uh
just for being centrists that's i mean
that's almost on
you know on a anecdotal level but
that's not a good sign um these papers
or records
are not the gatekeepers of information
anymore but they are
still hugely influential in how
most people understand what is happening
in this country in the united states
yeah i guess asking you what can be done
if you're in the uk
it's like well i'm perhaps moving at
some point
maybe do you think areas like uh texas
and florida are still going to have that
problem
uh i do but too to a smaller degree i
think
um because where where where the far
left has been able to
carry out acts of quantum political
violence it's not a state
whole statewide issue it's localized to
cities
so like portland seattle
and i know a lot i see messaging from
people
um when they're responding to my videos
they say oh
antifa wouldn't do this type of stuff
and in texas
well they there were far less blm riots
last year that happened
in austin for example that's in texas
you know so it's like
and there there's something there's the
nazi book group in austin texas called
the
um the austin red guard they've been
involved in political violence
so in any areas where
you have a local government like the
mayor and the city council who has
who are all democrats and all
sympathetic to this messaging
i think those are some of the the key
signs that
um when and if
uh left-wing political violence happens
that they're going to tolerate it
and they're going to throttle law
enforcement's ability to respond
and to pursue the charges against people
who may get harassed
okay that's that's scary that's very
concerning
i've been trying to figure out in the
last while given this like the coped
lockdowns in canada
been like maybe canada's not so great
it's really cold and dark
maybe it's not so great like where
should i go and
texas is looking pretty good compared to
canada
but the this whatever is going on with
leftists or far that extreme
left thing that's going on definitely
doesn't look good
um what do what do antifa and blm have
in common if anything
they hate shirt of the united states
that's primarily why they're allies
uh blm are they propagate a
black revolutionary marxist ideology
and that's not the that's not like my
labeling of this hyperbola that's
what the actual founders would describe
it and if you look at their writings
they will quote from marxist
revolutionary thinkers
uh murderers people like assata shakur
and stuff to read her poetry
at their events um so the communists
black communists um antiphon anika's
cognates and that distinction is
important
but for the time they're allied in that
they both want to
destroy the us turn it upside down
completely um they both have the share
and hatred
of law enforcement blm
uh claims that it's because law
enforcement
is racist and kills black people
intentionally
when you look at the data that's not
true you'll see
in the variables of all these instances
of
the one relatively consistent variable
in all these instances
where there have been um
police involved deaths of um
criminal suspects is that they resist
arrest
and um
i mean criminology is
the public the american public uh are so
ill informed on it uh like they don't
i mean essentially they have the
the rule they set up for when there will
be riots and looting in america is
essentially when
in anywhere at any point in america
there happens to be a black person
who is either injured and or killed by
law enforcement
you know if you're a country like
scotland
where there's 10 million people
okay like you know like or you're in a
country like sweden or norway
or iceland but here at you know in
the single digits of millions okay i
guess you know that's like
i mean it's like the american popular
the reason why i bring up these
different
population sizes is that these activists
don't seem they intentionally ignore
that the united states is a population
of 360 million
people and if your standard is if any
time
anywhere in the u.s there's at least
some help involves shooting the black
person you're going to
uh respond violently then there will
always be violence which is what they
want
um and you'll see over and over that the
people who are often involved in the
alumni are criminals
like actual convicted criminals these
are
um the people they choose to lionize are
also violent criminals
and often thugs as well and i
that's and i say that not
to argue that that's that then the
suspect should be killed on the spot by
police absolutely
not i throughout all my writings and in
my book i
you know i defend the rule of law which
includes due process and
and all that i bring this up just to say
that
the lionizing of these people as
angels that we should look up to that i
disagree with
i mean um they're essentially
encouraging
more people to resist the rest which is
what we see we see people
at these riots and protests not just
resisting arrest but assaulting police
and trying to pull away their comrades
when their comrades are in the process
of getting arrested like
all of that those type of actions will
increase your
the um possibility that law enforcement
would use force
against you or your group to get things
back
um in order so the
yeah i you know i don't
i think describing the alarm as a
terrorist organization
is not that's just inflammatory i
describe them as an anti-american
extremist group
they are extremists because they're
messaging extremists
um they talk about abolishing beliefs by
um coercion and violence you know they
talk about every city every town burn
the precinct to the ground
kicks in a blanket frying like bacon
like
this is incitement to violence and in
the us um
unfortunately we don't have laws that
can prosecute them for that in the in
the uk i'm not sure about canada
but you can be prosecuted by the state
for inciting violence and this is what
these people are doing
day in and day out on the streets and
then you see it and hear it clearly when
you're there
and then you open up the washington post
or the new york times
or you turn on the television and what
you're hearing is this is a peaceful
demonstration for racial justice
this is what this is what why part of
the reason why i'm black built
it's like you can show people
in unedited live stream video what is
actually being said
and done you can show them the us and
attacks you can show them
the people they've killed the riots last
year
weren't just looting and property
destruction you had dozens of deaths as
a result
of the george floyd blm riots in america
and people don't seem to take issue with
that like
that's why you're in the uk okay well um
two questions uh one how are you doing
are you like do you feel better being in
the uk how are you doing mentally
because this is a pretty big
and scary job that you've taken on and
that you're still doing
even though you nearly died so how are
you
um it's
it can be overwhelming to to never have
a break in that
the amount of time between uh
when political violence is breaking out
in some american city
it's like happening pretty much every
day now
and so it's really um
[Music]
there's a certain amount of emotional
drain to to be seeing that
this is what's happening in in my my
home country um
day in and day out
but but i i go on i fight on i've been
able to do a lot of reporting actually
from
here about the u.s still
because a lot of the information for
example like finding out
who's organizing and calling for
direct actions like that stuff doesn't
require you to be
in minneapolis for example i can be
online it could be anywhere i can work
from home and they just cove it
and another interesting thing is there's
been um
attempts by hard left groups in the uk
to
try to bring over the american style
of critical race theory and blm and
into mainstream media they've had
a little bit of success there was some
rioting that broke out
in uh in london
and in bristol last year in response to
george floyd
and i'm trying to identify the groups
and networks here that are involved in
that type of extremism
and also comparing and contrasting there
are certain things that the uk
law enforcement does so much better than
i've seen
in american police departments and this
is by the way without the benefit
of having um a lot of the
the tools the police here one are not
armed
two they're not militarized as they own
the u.s
and they have been often very effective
in shutting down these things
before it devolves into mass rioting
um but then there are also people who
are trying to
learn from the lessons in portland and
other places and
apply them here about um creating sort
of these support systems to
make it so that rioters can be bailed
out asap
get them back on the streets so um
yeah you know it's it's an international
problem the antifa is a global
movement they iron ironically or not
they're
they're most active in the the freest of
society
so um germany
uh uk scandinavia
france uh australia um
canada and the us so you know you don't
have antipa
in north korea or um china
or any any of these um uh autocratic
states in the middle east
like you have them in
prosperous western liberal democracies
so these are movements that are
attacking from within and
i hope more people wake up to it
particularly
governments you know that
if the government doesn't recognize that
2000 issue you're not going to be able
to
solve it and that's i think that's what
we see in the u.s the the federal
government doesn't see it as an issue in
in places in blue states governors and
such
like in in oregon or washington
you know they don't see it as a problem
so they're not going to have their
attorney generals
actually hold um to prosecute some of
these people who are doing
both local and federal crimes
i think a lot of people don't actually
recognize that it's a problem
like i've got a lot of friends on the
left
well fewer now but but i used to have
like all my friends were on the left
and um most of them don't think that
blm or antifa or any of that is anything
other than
supporting black people or trying to
make things more fair
and they really don't see this like
marxist or communist movement
behind it so i think it's just people
are not educated
and then it certainly doesn't help that
the mainstream media is like no they're
the good guys
because that's where most people
get their information or at least most
people on the left
so it's definitely a problem yeah
and you know in the early days of blm
nobody knew where this movement was
going to
have like what would be the actual um
empirical
outcomes of it but now that it's been
going on for years
in the u.s you can actually measure like
places where
um that have been most sympathetic to
their messaging city councils the
various uh legislations or
abolishments of various uh group
like parts of police departments by the
um due to blm pressure has resulted in
more people dying and that's an
empirical claim that you can actually
measure by looking at the levels of
violence
in response to more public awareness
about blm's messaging
so like i i'm opposed to blm and antifa
on two levels
one is ideological yes that that is my
bias
um as a um conservative journalist but
two i am against what they actually
produce their outcomes
it's misery and death and property
destruction and all that and these are
things that they actually
celebrate and just if you go on
communist with her and you just look at
what these people are saying by
communist twitter i'm referring to like
the networks of
communist users i'm not disparaging
twitter as a platform
although i i i i can't say bad things
about twitter and another
interview um if you look at what
communists are saying on twitter
um in response to the recent mass
looting um
uh north of minneapolis this week
they've been celebrating it they said
this is reparations
that capitalism property ownership
is linked to um slavery enslavement of
blacks
linked to white supremacy therefore we
need to
we need to steal or destroy property
that's just
justification for the scientific
justification when
they take bats to businesses one after
the other
okay well on that note
where can people find you if they want
to find you online and aren't following
you yet
thank you um i my website is andy
ngo.com um
you'll see all my my news articles my
interviews on there there's also an
option to
donate to um my crowdfunding
platform to support me since i i'm able
to do what i do full time because of
the generosity of my supporters um
i'm also on twitter and uh so twitter is
where you can see most of like the
newest info regarding riot coverage or
actually follow blm
okay thank you very much for coming on
that was enlightening a little bit
concerning but
definitely enlightening thank you for
having me on i really appreciate it
[Music]
you